alright one of our many roles is to keep
these basic species out of California to
protect the native wildlife so we're
going there and see if we can uh net
these foods out of here
we've had that kind of shark on display
for the last 13 years you know they come
in here you know send us a warrant for
our arrest it's ridiculous it's just
ridiculous I'm pissed off
how the hell are you crawl
I can see you again yeah you two good
bridge tell you that when me and Sonny
were here
she had her pepper spray out at my house
it almost came for
Thanks Thanks I could have been a port
you know this is I don't want to hurt
any of your guys stuff so can you
believe can you assist me in some way to
go ahead this is this is your guys
aquarium okay we're just here to take
the juice of ladder to get it oh I
didn't bring a platter Alice
I have a letter from the wholesaler that
we purchased it from and they're saying
that it's legal I feel we basically got
screwed this is a bunch of bull it's a
bull case and it should have never
happened
try it some more
come on you swam in the ocean before
more you didn't get it yet here spit a
little bit
I was bogging up I think Easter into the
aeration that's gonna make it hard to
find
it's coming out
I'm trying to get this shark in the net
it's not gonna be easy
there's a pole there thank you
there you go
so close coming your way
nice high you go you want to step down
Chris I go
which is watch deep no problem
very good good job it looks like he's
safe he's not hurt he's in the tank that
was a lot easier than I expected
one live with black tip reef shark my
name is Bethany mercy ensign here and I
can be copy that
okay thank you for corporation alright
next I goes in the garbage
it's like goo brawl how's that khaki I
don't think well it's kind of job to do
and know I'm in the next you know very
those four people said no one expose you
had to do see if you would learn to back
off in life believe me because someday
you're going to meet individuals that
are rough in this business and and
they'll give you a hell of a bad time
the right way is to be polite be a man
above everything okay well thank you for
the little information and you have a
good day mr. corporation okay guys take
care
people have a letís with us sometimes
and just goes with the territory
you gotta have a thick skin